you know I rant about Monday you hating
it and we've had iconic videos about
that situation I mean you know the real
the real question I've been debating is
how do I tell you what to do okay cool
I'll yell at you and say if you hate
your Monday then you've got to change it
you only have one life this and that
people like great Mazel Tov but what do
I do what are the steps and I've been
thinking a lot about it I think I think
one of the biggest steps is just to
bring patterns
when Edwards Jr was and there was like
my god this guy was in my farm this year
he's gonna close out the World Series uh
when he gave up that hit I was like uh I
mean the rain delay was on a whole
nother level and then all these pictures
on social media of kids that are like
predicted the Cubs in 20 there's some
kid with a yearbook for like the 90s
like Cubs to Cubs 2016 you heard it here
first
yeah I cannot believe the Cubs won the
World Series
I really can't need to do something you
either need to go to some Goodwill
stores buy some stuff and post it on
eBay like we've talked about you need to
reach out to 5,000 people on Twitter
that day that you admire and ask them if
you can have a cup of coffee we've
talked about that some of you've
successfully done that with me and Mark
Cuban them and the craziest
entrepreneurs and famous people in the
world you know so maybe that's what you
do
maybe on your call-out Tuesday you go
and go to six interviews for different
jobs that you've been holding off maybe
on your call-out Tuesday you know you go
and visit your grandmother or your dad
and have that conversation that you
needed to have whether that's I love you
or whether that's hey I'm not going to
be pinned down by your negativity
anymore I'm going to do it what's like
great so really a fun day just got it
Soraka you missed those we just taught
them how great showers are left this
morning for a wake-up call it's been a
hell of a day last night as some of you
saw because I was pushing pretty hard
today on social we had a pretty cool
event where our Budweiser commercial and
our Budweiser Facebook commercial the
way I call it video really really hit
big moment for vaynermedia great moment
for our client Budweiser I'm super
excited about it the AP you know every
sports blog all the industry rags just
emails that um emails from all sorts of
CMOS and marketers and former employees
so just really kind of hit the scene
pretty exciting really exciting because
we actually filmed the behind the scenes
of it so that's good for our teams I
don't know if we'll be able to use it
now as if not there's probably no
episode today unless we use this whole
narrative as I'm now going into another
big client thing fun thing for me to do
I just started doing these of them two
or three now where I do a wine event and
a State of the Union thing I call them
vintage a little fun play there right
little wine little vintage the year that
you live in you know marketing talk so
that should be great with our chase
client we can use that too that's public
so come a public dropping stearic um so
I'm excited about that and get together
with some of my buddies afterwards and
catch up with them as I'm about to
embark on almost two months in LA so
pretty good all good stuff
see I don't really have a great read on
Conor McGregor he's obviously done a
great job building his brand I think
he's got some clear marketing
capabilities so I don't have a great
great answer for you I definitely don't
know him as a man I love the competitive
spirit
I love the showmanship I'd love to know
what's under the hood in like his heart
and his soul and then I could have a
really great read but definitely clearly
has charisma marketing chops to build
his brand and clearly a good fighter you
know from what I could tell but I know
there's a lot of people from more
educated on that one thing I don't think
people use enough of is Twitter video
and snapchat like if I go to my snapchat
right now I'm not gonna screw with
screens but you know you know somebody
just came in here and said you know
thanks Sloane that little move that
little can't there's a little camera
here where you can like do the quick
little cameras takes a few seconds like
yeah lions and jets are just gonna be
waiting cubs inspired but we're gonna be
waiting brother you know those 3.5
seconds really meaningful death you know
I'm a big big big big big fan of Twitter
video reply
I just don't think people use it enough
you know I rant about Monday you hating
it and we've had iconic videos what if I
told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life about that
situation I mean you know the real the
real question I've been debating is how
do I tell you what to do okay cool I'll
yell at you and say if you hate your
Monday then you've got to change it you
only have one life this and that and
people like great Mazel Tov but what do
I do what are the steps and I've been
thinking a lot about it I think I think
one of the biggest steps is just to
break patterns right like you just have
to call out tomorrow you have to call
out Tuesday we have to create a call-out
on Tuesday and you need to do something
you either need to go to some Goodwill
stores buy some stuff and post it on
eBay like we've talked about you need to
reach out to 5,000 people on Twitter
that day that you admire and ask them if
you can have a cup of coffee we've
talked about that some of you've
successfully done that with me and Mark
Cuban and and the craziest entrepreneurs
and famous people in the world you know
so maybe that's what you do maybe on
your call out Tuesday you go and go to
six interviews for different jobs that
you've been holding off maybe on your
call out Tuesday you know you go and
visit your grandmother or your dad and
have that conversation that you needed
to have whether that's I love you or
whether that's hey I'm not going to be
pinned down by your negativity anymore
I'm going to do it you know motivations
exciting but the practicality of an
execution is even more importantly and
so I sit here today and I make this
video and I say it's a call out Tuesday
call out of work tomorrow
I'm excited see but it goes out of
intermedia call out of work tomorrow do
not go to school tomorrow do not do what
you normally do tomorrow if you hate it
today's Monday if you hated waking up
today if you loved the weekend if you
can't wait for Friday and do one those
four or five things that I just told you
or something else that yeah I haven't
done about or the reverse or the reverse
once you take your kids out of school
your kids are not gonna remember fourth
grade Tuesday English class but taking
them somewhere just you guys doing
something fun is something they'll
remember forever and so
that's what I want to do with this video
I want to inspire a call-out Tuesday
then action I don't wanna hear that you
slept in to 11:30 and just mope the
round and ate some fruity pebbles action
that we just talked about or something
else leave a comment below with what
you're gonna do on your call-out Tuesday
heading into a sauce for a business
meeting and then dinner with some
friends and pretty productive day just
got a ramp in a bunch of people gonna
take off Tuesday and well good feeling
good productive 24/7 365
you